foi bom dito primeiro chute em santa
catarina um de minas gerais um piauí
dando todo mundo né acabei de acordar
com o jã distanciar hoje é o dia de hoje
é o dia de mau e casa nova casa nó de
começar o vídeo hoje só quero dizer a
vocês que tudo cantando a vida
hoje vai ser um dia muito legal e eu
espero que vocês curtam bicho de um
bicho um aparelho que é o que negão aqui
é parede que limpa e agora aqui é
ostentar santa eu fui eu
eita para ele quem lá vai o que o kaká
kaká com a gente hoje estou fazendo uma
coisa de doido
meu pai vai ganhar tanto nome mas a vida
é assim porque as vias são como os
brasileiros da lista com as lanchas e as
pessoas como já disse que os pedestres
como os mas eu estou indo agora lá
namorar o tato ea gente está indo a
gravação simultânea
assim mesmo deixa roland brasilera no
torneio bem como anthony tô bem nosso
deputado no bairro e um resfriado aqui
tudo foi joão pra gente aí calma e moura
leu brasileira jeane cassiano todo mundo
junto
neste rápido porque nós que está aquele
que pode chegar é o do ipca
estamos chegando a moral tatu street
e ó nosso stand up você ainda não sabe o
[Música]
somente à tarde demais ela vai
colecionando leve
a taxa é de brian você não sabe onde vai
fazer todos os atuais dois morrem
sozinhas jeitosa a mesma a mesma ótica
encontrando o amor além da agitação me
leve o próprio é gol junto com o hit meu
pai vocês sabem quem para quem faz menos
ainda para na primeira tatuagem ele
fazer outros que são um símbolo que
representa a amizade eu fazer um gol de
caio
ele é fazer um rico righini é nóis vai
ser michou gente vai fazer
logo mais vai fazer outra pet um braço e
todo dia um fio lycra tulip ativa matar
na hora ea culpa toda de quem é amigo
não adianta
tomara deus é bicho surdo e assim eu
achei anache natas ou não mas ela estava
a mudar nada na minha vida é só um
símbolo me no meu corpo era chá pra
sempre e é isso aí galera olha você que
não sabe eu estou aqui
aqui nesta loja é a moral está todo o
centro aqui tá vendendo meu ingresso
está no novo escândalo rapazes não
parasse no monólogo então é aqui que
aguentar a galera ó com essa mulher que
essa mulher que estava vendendo chak mo
se eu quero ingresso rápido do índice
enquanto é até muito caro mas eu vou
porque eu sou tão fã dele que todo mundo
vai comprar eu vou levar minha família
inteira pra se divertir de montanha com
essa turminha do barulho aí cheguei aqui
com ela já era a compra só chegar e
pedir o ingresso está na pe
vim aqui na moral tattoo eu vou correr
aqui dentro porque até uma ficha de kart
não acho que esta gente na moral tatuam
do centro
aqui eu fazendo um [ __ ] saber neto e
o santos
organizar life news ótima foto nunes e
os remédio usado no dia 14 o dia 14 de
junho embora mas é muito bom que você
compre antes está com você confiança não
deixe para comprar só no dia porque
geralmente no dia acaba é muito rápido
então comprou antes se você quiser
postar uma foto do ingresso você com
ingresso me marca no instagram melhor
ainda porque eu vou perde só foto
postada no facebook a itália que o meu
nome do senhor que o vírus só tomando
aquele velho cabo antes de fazer a
toalha e não segura
eu tô aqui todo dia apaixonada por você
é assim ai galera
o vieira todo dia pra noite na praça
ramos na praça da moral tattoo lyon já
tomar aquele café já que ele entendeu
que a propaganda pa ganhar não a gente
vai pagar tomou tanto comigo é assim é
fácil ser bicho san josé 28 de novembro
que eu estou no ataque pedindo socorro
vamos fazer só torcem tomar pelo menos
um caso e aguentar o jornal desmaiado
quem é você que já acorda tomando
guaraná de agora o comando de uma coisa
muito eu estava começando a me sentir
mal de verdade então hoje eu vou começar
uma vez seria membro aliado aquelas
coisinhas tomar o carro de manhã
aquele cara de mon dieu vieira
nós então isso aí só pra você ver a
galera não sabem que tomando café de
kubrick
esse rapaz bem que ele trabalha no
estacionamento e ele acabou de dizer pra
gente que a namorada dele cut os vídeos
da gente ele também conseguir agora
vocês pensarem na felicidade na alegria
que a gente tem de hoje a gente no
primeiro gol elano na primeira hora de
pôr no carrinho aqui cara de salgado ou
3 a 1
me chamo saco passando tomando a
propação seu advogado achar que um
sorriso do ensaio eu tivesse tanto que
assistindo àquela coca cola ou falamos
patrocinador já sozinha ela e emerson é
só pra isso é isso aí não é nem o cara
falou assim a gente espera aumentar o
seu poder total carta branca para
experimentar a roupa e já era vou
experimentar a roupa que eu quiser a
galera pensa agora vocês vão aparecer
com a roupa nova
o andor termina aí já a galera porque aí
eles falaram que a gente queria ter
carta branca que vestir o que quiser
escolher pagar qualquer roupa ea gente
escolheu mesmo embora se chove por falar
é nóis na fita o som abre sempre em mim
não falta
acho que eu fui o único a não fazer
jornalismo 2011 trabalha naquele vinho
[Música]
pois é agora ainda estamos esperando
ainda pra fazer nossas atuais vêm aqui a
minha tia que quem fez o webm
westerwelle em fazer a outra e anais
depois todos vivem
depois de todo o desfile maravilhoso ver
aí é não acho nada
a galera já terminou
já estou ficando aquele jeito que ela
anda fazendo tatuagem
eu estou só pensando se ele realmente
gostou a cirurgia só vou falar porque à
tarde é muito grande tem que falar três
figurinhas de uma vez só de eu fui tirar
completar a moral é só gente negro não
vamos ganhando a falha que a minha
medial
aqui tem impacto legais do monte de
gente eu quero que vocês já namoravam se
conhecer
a oceana não na aí o barulho do motor e
se eu falei eu ia dizer que você saiu
leandro jogou certo
a bruna que é muito legal e vocês vêm
comprar o ingresso do meu da minha peça
que está a gente chegava no bruno aquino
ingresso do show stand up
ela detém quanto é que vai ser o preço é
até muito caro mas mesmo assim você como
está com o ombro vantagem ante muito
obrigado ao cabelo
o fábio mas a toalha fase é fazer turnos
makita vamos lá todo mundo tá tomando
até o chão tatua tatuagem tattoo vale no
senhor van natta andam a dar chance a
gente agora o homem teve o estado está
fazendo a galera estou entrando aqui tem
mandato a ela é mesmo
mas o jec é o homem da máquina mais
silenciosa
olha eu estava aqui só deixou a noção
que leiam o livro então a cota normal do
passado
eis por que eu vou mandar a partir de
vídeo vê-se agora vai fazer depilação no
tiroteio um bom fã já não vou malhar
manacá e tira do paraná
ae a pec acaba de cair de fun a chance
de alisamentos meia manso dó ficou show
mas o time ficou desse jeito ele lhe
valeu valeu galera acabou isso aí a
tatuagem é nova bnv
minha vida mesmo dente shopping do norte
começará a tortura aqui que os ingressos
no mundo vai ter um novo estádio e 14 de
junho
e eu quero muito você vá então tá vendo
aqui na maior operação do centro está
também na rádio tal modo já aconteceu
chega lá e com a proposta foto ingresso
de marca no restaurante é nóis a rua é
nossa
dói ainda mais porque agora a mãe
chamada mais ela mexe cavaco
pensando e se hoje do sol volte em que a
primeira parte da primeira parte da
tarde nada para a gente sair com a
inadimplência que pintar
agora vamos apagar a pintura que a par
da tortura que a partir de satanás na
vida das pessoas
galera agora é minha vez de tapauá
ele tá [ __ ] nele
olha aí não mostra agora
ae o sangue no vídeo quando pintado
ademar do outro
castel toma um empate aqui e sempre
assim né é basta mais tinta forjando que
na pele tudo de verdade
ae o ambiente aqui é muito bom e tem os
cabelos impecáveis tour
eu deixei carro e na casa dele
agora vai ser assim daqui lá vou ficar
tirando isso deixará na cabeça dele sabe
de nada culpado pois a galera terminamos
a minha amiga terminada e daqui a pouco
quem tiver começado praia três eixos a
galera minha vez agora 26 de céu agora
vocês vão ver qual médico de hoje que
vai ter tanto destaque aqui vai ter o
dia de hoje
o olheiro da águia também vamos afinar
anos assistente é nosso entender a folha
está fazendo aquilo e ainda não tava
lendo não está sendo capaz de hoje
gradiente serão em brasília um sacador o
[Música]
zero sem pontas lecce na segurança
deixado três funções
ai ai ai
i shimbalaiê
[Música]
mas a chance de ganhar passar de fase
galera que é chato mas eu quase no
twitter fotos é botar o ovo pra nós
tomar com uma pizza de que era feita de
meninas e agora é mas não é não olhou a
galera ficou show do dow equipe e
continuo um homem sair ainda não tenha
gatos é a diferença é assim daqui eu sou
a favor
à noite já que um do que o tac ou têm
prometido aqui não é baratear vereda com
a secretária o meu deus que eu tatuei
noel pra galera
logicamente não é que a galera quero
esse amor ao tartufo por ter
proporcionado a quantidade de trabalho
pra gente é tudo o que ela tinha pegado
puro esquerda gente pois agora o vídeo
acaba por aqui na moral e é isso aí
segue em baixo tendo a sua dos media a
imagem do barcelona tem um livro dá
moral dessa tragédia primeira vez na
descrição do vídeo é o link da página da
fan page aqui na moral tattoo e aí você
vai lá e você dá um livro na paz e
comida lá puxa uma tatuagem do izma no
gráfico muito boa
muito obrigado a todos e você se sente à
vontade de jogar e você se sentiu mal e
vocês que estão aí e você está aí senti
à vontade de fazer a tatuagem alguma
coisa
e por indicação chega aqui fala senão
dobrado isso a gente tem que fazer a
tatuagem da piores bem mas pode vir na
semana depois da derrota pois a galera
pois é isso aí é nós valeu estamos a
cada elemento da brigada mesmo é se você
tiver gostar de sair do veículo o tio
acho engraçado achou ruim acho que vai
ter no inverno não é tatuador
a opção está tudo dando certo pois é
pois é isso aí
muito obrigado você dá um aqui embaixo
ae obrigada chega aqui é que não gostei
que embaixo e começa em baixo se
inscreve no canal
a gente morre ninguém gente é porque a
gente tá brincando mesmo com o porquê
tipo assim que a gente estava brincando
com esse símbolo vem dizendo que a não
ser que queira desenvolver assim que as
sensacionais que ainda não sabe qual
kate usava em troféus assim mas a
brigada militar bm também analisa que
está bom pois é essa e mais brincadeira
mesmo na parte que é pai de um ator é
nóis vai se você vai ficar na terra
jamais vai cantar então ele vai comer
cuscuz que mais gostar jesus
este ano